um when I say forest I mean and Samba or
trees and I'm going to talk about how in
scikit-learn we in Samba trees so very
generic forest so ii learn commonly is
uses of the supervised learning problem
oh my god
where you have your given x and y and
you wondering this function that maps
from x to y in this talk I'm gonna have
xB 2d and samples my n features and y is
one T how many of you have used the
cyclone API familiar with it okay it
creates a it's a very nice interface
where you could create a model you could
call fit to train your model you call
predict to predict and a lesser known
thing you could call score to get the
score for classification its accuracy
and for every question is are to score
so that's API so let's jump right into
it what's a tree all right decision tree
is where has this tree at this isn't
tree is where your your sample start off
at the root node and end up at the leaf
node do binary zillions so on the on top
if you're a petal with is less than 0.8
goes the left if it's if it's more equal
to the right and it's gonna another leaf
and then use that leaf for prediction so
if it ends up in the orange one it's
it's it's gonna be classified as the
first cost because that's the majority
class in that leaf now growing a tree
well if you add a node and you want to
split this node into its children you go
to every feature you sort that feature
you find the split point in such a way
that you're chose it minimizes impurity
of children that means at the parent you
want your children to be more pure than
pure than you are so this is the whole
growing process
so that's tree growing we have and it
grows until it reaches stopping criteria
the way you control is do these type of
parameters and our decision tree
regression classifier there's max M
example leaves there's a lot of them but
today I want to specific about forest
since we have been a forest classifier
and regressor where you go many trees
it's controlled by a high performing a
call and estimators but the fourth
hundreds are go to hundred trees but if
the trees are exactly the same they can
predict exactly the same thing so
averaging them would not be and do you
any good so you want the great happy
little trees where you have bootstrap
you
we shop sampling we're which means
you're gonna sample with replacement and
for classification for every split we
don't look at every feature you can look
at a subset features
this adds diversity in the Jafar's which
gives which means it learns different
parts of you take it outside when you're
average them it gives you a better
prediction so Brendan for is very cool
how do you implement it well I'm in
scikit-learn
our key building is we don't write NP R
Python you have to be slow so we write
insight on how many you are tightened
yeah sight sounds cool I'm gonna show
you lots of site on all right our site
on releases to kill okay very important
for later forest building uses a job
limb which is paralyzed with Joplin what
is job limb job is a it defines a very
simple API for paralyzing code every
anyone can use this to palace that goal
so by default it uses multiple processes
in this case I want to damage it the API
you create a parallel object in this
case and drop to get for it that means
it uses four cores I'm you have to delay
your function because you want to make
it lazy and then you iterate it to in
this case it's a squares a squared
square root the square and so it does
this in parallel so it's very simple to
paralyze your code how we do we take
advantage of this with tree building
well for tree bearing we define the same
object but in this case we preferred
writing because our sights on cold
releases to kill so this we use multiple
threads and since the site releases the
Gil we could take advantage multiple
cores and so we do the same idiom we
delay the function call and then this
works so this is what we do this is the
actual code of how we paralyze random
forest building
okay so random forest is very quick what
school was what was introduced in 0 21
which is histor gradient boosting
which is our its own from the decision
of his ingredient listing inspired by
like GPM so how many of you have used
like IBM Kappas actually booze this is
another this is a formula this is an
we've had our own implementations like
learn that's on par with lech p.m. I
gave a very detailed talk about this
three weeks ago and encourage you to
look at it I'm gonna give a very quick
elevator pitch of how this works and
this one very quick booth thing is
very generic machine learning concept
where you will each you want to create a
function you just function when I learn
would be a sum of many other functions
and you train this iteratively
you build a zero and then you bear each
one based on H zero and so four and so
on generator is something called
adaboost that does this but today I want
to talk about gradient boosting when you
think of gradients you have lost
functions so for requestion we have V
squared at least absolute deviation for
classification we have cost MGP now once
you have a loss function which is a
scalar value we want to take the
gradient for example V squared
it's just difference and you square it
and someone all up it's a scalar value
but the gradient is a vector value which
means every sample has a corresponding
graded with it which I'll come to this
point later what do you do these
gradients well for grading boosting you
start with an initial condition for
least squared you just take the mean so
this is the most naive prediction you
could think of which is the mean of your
training set no it's the target of a
training set and then the recursive
condition adds different functions to
this prediction to make it better this
is not great in the sense you're not
updating weights you're adding different
functions on top of the previous
predictions very different distinction
so I promise is the last math equation
put on the side this is the end of the
day deliberately so in this case for at
least squared each of em it's gonna be a
leg of gradient and you look closely at
H of M of X we're chopping now is having
a sub problem we want to find H of M
such as a mass of X to Y minus the
previous prediction so it's now we're
stopping a sub-problem iterally so how
do you solve hmm
how do you get each of them well since
this is a do you want to go too far in
stock is trees and how do you build the
trees this is the history has been great
in boosting his to form histograms we
need to have bins and the first thing we
do is pin out data so in this
visualization the X is the row index and
the Y is the feature
value and so to pin out data set we take
that last in this case tendons last
simple set of data becomes 0 the next
ten percent becomes 1 and so four and so
on so we discretized our feature space
after that since each feature has this
corresponding gradient you could put
them in these bins so in this case
there's 5 pins and we replace I can sum
them up and place them in their bins so
these are some of gradients we also need
Hessians because the Algrim needs it
it's kind of hand wavy but after we Ben
it this is where the speed of outcome
comes from so this is for overview of
the algorithm we've been the data first
as we saw before make an initial
prediction which is a constant for V
squared as a mean then we since we have
a prediction now we could calculate the
gradients but to get a difference and
then the tree building process we've
been we've been the data as shown like
this this the cool thing about pinning
in the data is that you have your split
points or not or set in stone they're on
the order of how many but I'm a bench
you have so it's yeah but your since
your future space is now smaller and the
bins are ordered so you don't have to
sort your data anyway once you've been
the data you have a sore thumb so this
greatly speeds up the algorithm for his
new grading boosting this is what makes
like you've been fast and what makes
history great increasing fast that's the
gist of it so how do you make this how
do we implement this in cycle urn
couldn't use pure Python it'll be as I
said before it would be slow could be a
site on yes we do your site on but you
usually compile with OpenMP all right so
I'm gonna show you some site on code
which almost looks like Python code and
it's I'm gonna Steve show you what it
looked aches to make this parallel okay
so for bin data once once we bend it we
have to place the features in a bin
which is a binary search so if you stare
at this this is binary search but it's I
saw you the site on but if I wasn't tell
you that it would look like pure Python
all right so this is site on is that
cool you know you could write just
Python and just run in this case if you
look at the top its range so this is in
serial if I want to make this parallel I
just change this range to your P range
and this is all it takes to make this
code take advantage all your course okay
so it's very simple in this manner so
I'm gonna show you in a few more
examples when you split when you find
the best bit yet go to every feature you
could use independently so we could
multi-processing on p range you could
change the range of p range and
will speed up the finding the features
find the best bit point for each feature
so okay so that's so it's cool
next is and samples it could paralyze
over and samples and you do the same
thing this is all what this is doing
it's writing to memory and we're doing
in parallel and boom it's faster so
compiling you if you write sites on and
you want to make you if you take
advantage all your course you could
compile it against OpenMP and it will
make and just makes much slightly
changes and it would make it go faster
so it's awesome so that the boosting
process if you go back and look at API
for the boosting process and histone
gradient boosting there is some
parameters controlled boosting notice on
the top we need an able history goosing
to import this it's our magic it because
our hits and grading boosting is kind of
experimental so you have to import that
for to use have some great boosting next
their learning rate and Max adored prime
minister pace on boosting max it er is
how many trees you want to add to your
how many steps of boosting you want to
take that's how many trees you have to
if you want to grow the eggs there's an
environmental variable where you control
how many cores you want to use so you
set this before you've run your yours
process so if I want to compare let's
say I want to do some benchmarking so I
wanted the standard benchmarks we do is
the higgs-boson
dataset which is eight point eight
million records and twenty eight
features it's a classification problem
if we want to run this and use like GPM
or SK learn there the time is about the
same it's around 30 seconds on two of
course the accuracy and our z-score is
about the same as well so this is
expected since we our implantation is
based on the veggie permutation but the
difference is that we write it in sight
on and the implantation C++ there's
that's the only difference
most of us don't have 12 core machines
so if you have four cores it's gonna
take more time but it's gonna have some
accuracy so it's it's comparable for
course as well so this is how we
paralyze are the trees and for random
forests we have sites on which releases
to go and job Lib that does
multi-threading for histor gradient
boosting recite on and openmp the big
differences each tree could you trained
independently so you can put in both the
course in the train insanity
the green of boosting Archie's train
Italy so it's so in this case to make it
faster we have to make the growing of
the tree faster and this is what that's
why we chose these techniques now after
we train these models all these trees
what can we do with them after between
these trees what can we do with them
well we could inspect them in mono
inspection we have permutation points
and partial dependence we also have plot
pressure dependence so I want to show
you what permutation importance is
without any math it's gone I'm gonna
show you with an example okay let's say
I want the permutation points of the
first feature of this data this is just
pretend date I made this up it's not
real it's a classification problem I'm
gonna fit my data and I'm gonna score it
and so this is classification it's gonna
be accuracy yeah accuracy afterwards I'm
gonna commute the first column though so
you see the first column was ordered
here I'm gonna computer I'm just gonna
shuffle it and then I'm gonna score it
again so yeah and it's gonna give you no
numbers in this case 70% I'm gonna
premiered it again I'm 73 I could keep
on doing this you know I keep on doing
this for as long as I want and I say I
do or three times and remember the
original score was 90% so the the
definition of permutation featurepoints
is going to be the difference between
these so in this case I took the
difference that you get something like
at the bottom the insight about this is
if a feature matters if you permute the
score if you commute the column it would
drop that as a score drastically because
it matters but if it doesn't matter
commuting the future will get would not
drop the score at all because it doesn't
matter so that's the basic intuition
around permutation importance so I did
this is quite manual here but as I could
learn we have permutation points which
would do this order do this for you so
in this case you shouldn't do it three
times but I did three times in exam so
it's I said repeats equal to three but
you can't do it you should do a lot more
times and what it returns to you is a
dictionary where the keys are the
endpoints this which is the raw berries
that you saw before is this the wrong
computer and whew
importance and then it is for ease of
use we include the sanitation and the
mean of the samples so let's look at
this let's look at future importance for
Ivo dataset Rio isn't the Titanic this
that um we have a fetch open ml which
allows you to access lots of datasets on
the open ml the server and in this case
IMAX a satanic this is new and 0:22 I
could use as friend equal to true which
would return a data frame okay and
afterwards I'm gonna add a fandom
category give a number into the data
frame alright so these things are just
noise they do not matter at all
okay I'm gonna barely add things into it
how many of you have used pandas and
secular together okay cool I'm gonna
show you something awesome how many you
have used calm transformer column a
transformer okay I'm gonna show you
column transformer I always I always
like to plug this whenever I can so I'm
gonna plug it now I'm gonna look at only
like a several columns though there's
good this data set has categoricals
and numerix right so I'm gonna go guys I
subset of them and I'm since we're great
diet science is you know we're gonna
train test fit them and this is the
column transformer alright so I'm gonna
create a pipeline just for the
categories so this gets categories has
missing values so I'm gonna it with the
word missing and then I got 100 so this
is this only makes sense for categorical
features you're not you're gonna get not
gonna do this for numerical features and
I'm gonna have something very simple for
the numeric so I'm just gonna I'm cute
the mean okay so what the comp
transformer is it allows you to create
this single transformer where like where
you could specify the categorical
columns and know it will pipe in that it
passed the data in these in these
columns by name into the category
pipelines so only so this specifies that
the category pipeline runs on the
categorical features and same thing for
the numeric ones if you could see it
so this way after you have this
transformer you could place this into
another pipeline and then and then pass
it into a vent for its classifier
because this is do you want a bit of
forest okay
so and then you call fit and the cool
thing about this is X chain is a data
frame it's going to pass through the
column transform and in the transform
its gonna run different transformations
based on the column name and then it's
gonna fit is gonna train your model okay
so that's it like a slight detour and
column transformer it's awesome use it
I'm gonna advertise it it's been around
for like two years or something and use
it awesome okay so the accuracy of this
model is why I found to be sound
training which sure but the test set is
eighty-one percent so how many of you
have used feature points from a tree
before so this all right so this is the
feature points of this tree alright you
can see that the random number is the
most important feature okay so that
doesn't make sense much right it turns
out that the van forest is heavily
biased toward high carnality features
because it has many different places
like since the venom has so many places
to split it's gonna choose it more often
than not because it has high carnality
so what permutation points gives you is
the way to get feature importance I
think so you can run for primary station
points on the test set and it will give
you a way to and then you can see that
the numbers and the branded category
does not matter in this case so it gives
you this power and which is very nice
but before you go around and just like
who I'm gonna use permutation points
everywhere I'm gonna give you some
warnings I'm gonna show you with another
data said so this is the breast cancer
data set where the its classification
cancer or no cancer I'm gonna train test
bit this I'm gonna train a van for its
classifier because do you want to go too
far is it's gonna have 97% accuracy and
I'm gonna run permutation points on this
so what happens here
well nothing it's important all right so
like the most important thing it's like
it's 0.008 right but what's going on
what's going on well it turns out most
of the features are
correlated so if you have correlated
features and you shuffle a feature
that's correlated the fit missions still
there right you could so the the squat
doesn't drop because the features stow
it is in the data set so that so which
means that you don't you don't get if
you don't get the proper permutation
points from this model from the
fermentation importance so what do you
do about the situation is you see that's
big yellow block they're all just
correlated and there's a tiny little
blocks in the bottom well you just
select one of the features in the block
all right so it's it's very simple
concept but it's very important when you
use permutation importance so I'm gonna
select these features I'm gonna train it
I ran in class Safari I'm gonna do the
trains have split like yeah so I'm gonna
try another one it's gonna be 97 percent
same exact accuracy as before I'm gonna
do the permutation points again and you
see that now stuff makes sense like yeah
the mean radius and mean concavity and
the mean text like these are important
so this is one way to inspect how your
models behave with your features so it's
it's more inspection so that's
permutation points I want to talk about
parts of the penance I won't explain
this without math again this used to be
math here but there's no math anymore so
because they so I'm gonna have this data
set it's regression this time it's a toy
did is that now I'm gonna fit this model
and you notice that I don't want to find
a partial dependence on the first column
first column again the first feature so
what I do is you notice that the first
feature is it's ordered just for make it
easier I'm going to set the first column
to all zeros and I'm going to predict
this prediction is gonna give me five
numbers because it's five columns let me
take the mean let's say it's 0.1 all
right I'm gonna do it again for the one
and from the first column and I'm gonna
predict again so I'm keeping everything
else constant and changing just the
first column to a one and two a constant
am I gonna keep I could keep on doing
this I could do it for one two three I
just keep on doing it I can make a plots
okay so this plot on the plot turns out
to be something on the left so as this
feature increases the the prediction
increases
this means it has an influence on your
model it makes it so this is this is the
part of dependence if it was flat that
means it has no influence over the
protection of your model okay so this is
the essence of partial dependence so
let's run it - or the the cancer data
that we had before we have histogram
gradient boosting that's right and
remember we have to do the experiment so
import enable history gradient boosting
and I'm gonna fit I'm going to score it
it's gonna be in 97% so I'm gonna show
AIDS up the plot partially the Pens API
it's in its new it's just applying a PI
is neon 0.22
I'm gonna this filter it its plot part
independence needs the estimator the
data you want to train on and in this
case I want to pass it and comms equal
to because I want to columns it's gonna
why because I'm gonna pass features
equal to these things these are the top
four features from permutation points
not by coincidence
and so these I want to plot these four
parts parentage these parts of the
pendants plots so once I do that I'm
going to create this plot two columns
it's gonna give you all this stuff and
as you see that for all these features
as the mean radius i mean--can cavity
the mean texture grows gets higher
this feature is go lower but let's say i
let's yeah again so yeah so I think as
it increases the probability of the
cancer decreases as these things
increase now let's look for comparison
let's look at what it looks like for the
top two are the the top the top three of
the most important according the
permutation points the next two are not
important according this warrant a
permutation points the bottom two so
let's see what happens for that case so
the first two is what you saw before the
bottom two is what was not important so
increasing the means mootness or the
texture error would or more flat
compared to the top two so it's kind of
way expects if you look closely and
squint you notice that the plot partial
dependence returns this
this object the cool thing about this
API is that well parting partial
dependence is kind of computationally
expensive
yeah it's a lot of work so the disk jekt
stores these things inside is in the ID
object that means if you want to give
you plot this and be like it's ugly I
want to make the line thicker all right
so I could set the line width equal to 4
and I set the keyword of line with the
other four and as a dictionary
just forget goes who uses map father who
loves map father
ok I told him that I think so it could
set the line blind with is a property
that you could set on lines and it would
make the line thicker on all of them so
what this did was well the partial
dependents would not be calculated it
was it's already stored in the object
and I'm just gonna set the line width on
the when I plot it I could pilot again
with Robbie we computing anything
there's more into this object
remember there's four lines here so it's
stores stores the artists which is in a
grid and you could do whatever you want
to town you could set the line worth to
ten the line style two dashes a sec
color to red I'd say hello world on the
axis on the bottom and yeah animals like
this so you could kind of go nuts yeah
because and you could go nuts because it
it doesn't compute anything it just sets
change the style of your plots so that's
awesome
so partial attendance we're going
through a lot today okay like really
quickly but we have sites on reuse site
line and Joppa for Van Voorhis sites on
an open mp4 paralyzation inspection we
have permutation points and plot parties
dependents so these are these multis
inspection tools or model and gnostic
they don't have to be far as this for
this to work all the things talk to
stuff I have for my inspection they
could do you could do it for any model
you want you could do for dinner
let this aggression and regression and
everything all right so don't have to be
trees and I do want to show this demo
that's why I had this home since his'n
gradient boosting is that is the newest
estimate
have and like a learn and with Nick
spent six months on it and I want to
show kiss and it sparks joy that it's
worked so well I'm gonna share this joy
with you by showing you a demo
alright and of the day demo I hope it
works this is ssh into a 12 core machine
alright can you read that now okay
alright so i'm remember i have the
export in this case this core this
computer has 12 cool physical cores and
24 threads
open them p it's not good at handle
multi-threading I mean not not good at
handing hyper threading all right so I'm
gonna set open ohmmm P number 8 to 12 so
which makes it so that uses 12 physical
cores the script I use is the same
benchmark I use for the numbers I got
before and this is Brennan reports mode
which means that it's gonna give you
lots of detail about the death of your
three slow trees are training how long
it took if you see if you look on the
bottom you see that 12 cores are being
used like 100% so this is a cool look
like this wasn't passed this is possible
because we can compile site down below
at MP and this is it's fast it's great I
don't know why we want to watch this but
it's works mmm let's not talk so come
all the slides are on this get home I'm
Thomas JB fan on Twitter if you caught
them you about things and thank you for
coming
[Applause]
[Music]
we want to include more the model
inspection field is developing as a
research topic and these parts of
dependence and permutation ponens has
been around longer and so we include
them which should be included and we so
happened to include permutation points
for this release I think so we want to
include more because it turns out
inspecting your models and see how they
and see how they behave is important to
us so these techniques
it's the beginning like I meet
personally I do wants more inspection
tools so that you can inspect your
models and get more insight about what's
going on we it's getting there so for
certain benchmarks it's the same speed
as IBM what we wants also 4422 it's
missing values so you could put missing
values and it works as well so it's
that's very cool what's what we want
more from it is native categorical
support because you could train trees
much faster if there's a night native
way to do categories that's in general
for any tree and we want to support
sparse
yes you guys one hand code sometimes
even one hand coding and running through
tree you need a very deep tree to
recreate what will happen if you just
natively have category categories and
your algorithm so there's there's ways
like it's very good now for this it's
very good now and we will improve as as
time goes on for the next release we're
working on this these ideas old ones are
so they're yes
no they're they're both exists
concurrently they're happy to that kind
of happy together I recommend you using
this because it's it's it's been very
good because it's it's written to take
advantage of multi processing yeah you
could use end jobs instead in this case
you have to set the environmental
variable it's very easy available we can
I haven't thought about that I don't
know we're gonna kind of power against
Korra but for here foresight on it was
very easy to get it to work with open em
OpenMP hoping i'm p like GPM also uses
open MP and actually beats all together
in peace so it's kind of standard so
this is r and we ran it's the yeah it
was the best tool for the job
library or just so hard for this it's
for we do have two other plotting
functions that also has the API it's
called plot plot for shipment recall and
plot RS CA you see so we have the we
have it and we want to expand this API
for all the planning authorities so
every planked utility from here on we'll
have will return the disk object storing
the competition so that you could change
the style after the fact and not
recalculate like this is the goal like
we will have a lot more and zero the
next release
[Applause]